[Music]
many people told me that I was crazy
because it protects against animals that are not
worth it but it is worth it because
these animals are evolving from
being prehistoric animals this
is 20 m long now it is 2 meters
long then  It is something that I
am proud of with these animals
[Music]
my name is Ramón Medina Archundía I am the
owner of the inventory here in
downtown Manzanillo
with these animals I started 41 years ago
[Music]
I identify with the most
unprotected animals people in certain
At times they were used for
human consumption and for use as skins, belts,
shoes and handbags were being actively followed
by animal rights
activists. There are still people who
kill them for pleasure.
We have few species at one time.
We have about 40 iguanas.
We have been with them for so many years
[Music]
in hot weather the animal eats
approximately 300 kilos to 350
kilos of food per day and in
cold season the animal eats very little because it
enters the mating season of
reproduction of that cycle of two
life cycles that they lead
my family has supported me a lot
in this project that is very difficult
because it is every day  one cannot
say that today I am not going to clean I am not going to
feed them
for me they are part of my family I
feel sorry when a little animal dies I feel sad because animals are
part of my life I love them they love me
they also
see that  pay some respect to the
animals not let them
go to follow the animals that follow
to continue media still being produced
for people and future generations to
see this animal and things
and
[Music]